光栄なことだと思っております
まあ友情三者意見か良ければまあ私の普段の話自分の主題に大事にしている手段ついて
お話をいたします
まあ私の母が日本人です体父はアメリカ人ですそして私はポストんアメリカのボストン
のキター
ブーブーイングランドというところで
育ちました本当に当時は周りが吐く
真っ白でした雪が多いっていうだけではありません
白人の桜 a コミュニティで育ちました私の母以外
そして母の家族以外日本人は周りにはいませんでしたし
周りに私のような頒布というものは人は
今見当たりませんでしたいい
て私はまあこういうプロホッケーをしていたんですけれども
ベンチに座っていた時になかったらこういうところにこのい母が父親と来たんです
けれどもそのキー仲間が
うわぁお母さんは中国人だなんて知らなかったという風に言われたんですねでも私は
あえて訂正はしませんでした訂正をする必要性も感じなかったのです
でも待ったじゃあ別の機器
第2
あ日本人のお母さんでヒョンジンの家族だったらか
例えば魚をなんて食べるのと言われたことがあります
でそう言われて立つ所に思い浮かべるのがまあ生の魚を頭からそして尻尾をこうやって
l
持ち上げてそして口をパクパクさせているような魚をガリガリかじっている自分を想像
してしまう
たんですがそんなものは食べられないですよね子供の頃
そう言いながらも自分は日本に文化はすごく強い強い精神性があるなあというふうに
感じているしたーー
て私が成人して日本に住みをなりなったんですけれどもこれはバブルが崩壊して
ずいぶん後のことですっで皆さんは日本の経済が付い不携帯をしているというふうに
その当時言ってましたんでね
もうその当時の日本の経済はかなり
持続可能性
があるそして文化的なかなり堅牢だというふうに思ったんですです
なので停滞や賃貸アジアの病人だと言われているアジア人の中での日本というのはどう
してこのように強くあるのかという風に考えました
そういうことで私は本当に
いいじゃあ方にはあの土台としても非常に強い力があうんというふうに思ったのですね
なのでこの土台としての力というのはこれは日本メール米たいなのか賃貸なのかそれと
もこれは持続可能性という力なのかということを考え始めました
特に
先進諸国では本と同じような状態にある国が多いです
人口減少
そして貧困は上昇そういった仲間の国の中でも低い日本が強いはどうしてかということ
を考え始めました
で日本によく住んでいらっしゃる方は分かると思うんですけれども
例えば頑張るっていう言葉があります英語で言えば一生懸命戦う
どんな状況
今日でも最善を作っというよとは意味合いですっってこれは東北のザ大地震の後の
ボランティアの皆さんの写真ですこの時
がんばるって言うような掛け声というのはこういったが困った状況でも最善を出すと
いったようなそういったへ見合い
で使われる言葉ですでも日常的に使われる言葉でもあります頑張るという言葉は毎日
日常的にサラリーマンが通勤をする時に入れも
か映画と示しているようなんですけれども
サラリーマンのお父さんの家族の人たちが頑張ってねっと色てらっしゃいというような
ことを言うわけです
a これは本当ございまーずいぶん長く遅くまで働くので本当に頑張る
一生懸命しなければいけないというか状況が発生します
もう一つ注目する言葉として我慢という言葉があります英語では例えば i 忍といっ
たような意味合いです
このデー原則というのは
手一杯なんでも何でも大丈夫ということですもあんでそれは文句を言いたい
泣きを入れたりすることなく頑張るということです買うよ
例えば東京のような都市の中で
皆様の超金電車が中に入るとびっくりすちゃんにします
熱湯の方々がこの混雑の中で携帯を回したり読めるようにしたりあるいは俺って本当に
驚いてしまいますアメリカのニューヨーク3風呂 c そこで本当にいい人がいっぱい
の好きでしょ
はくると人は乗らないんですもうタクシーに乗ったりあきらめるわけですでも日本は
違います
日本では1位はどれほど通勤で者がコンピューターの我慢して乗りますよ
次の言葉は自粛ですっご存知の方もいるかと思うんですけれどもこれは抑制する自己
抑制をするということで自分の4
方が思っていることを抑制するということですね
バッターへの薄い目でこの考え方ての畳パーン
10習熟プールスクリーン
を冷気を係数姉よるシーン釣果
あの電気が足りないということであれば電気を節約するために電気を消して pc の
画面の明かりだけで何とかしのぐということをします
アメリカのコンセプトではまあ
て頑張るとでも欲しいものは栄養と言ったような考え方がまあ
大きくはびこっていますでこの自粛というのはまた却下良い方向おいてますっ
ぎゃーいた日本のコンセプトも合わせてみると支出してい
あっておりこれがもしかしたらバー日本の社会の長がを持続可能性に導いているもので
はないかと思うのです
日本は今停滞人体をしていると言われています
失業率は3.4%停的素敵にば低いところにはメス賃貸をしていてもう失業率は低い
そしてあの犯罪列から考えてもしか日本はとても安全なところだと言われております
day
これを考えるとどの本かでも本品が見舞われるような硬いに見舞われるはずであります
どそして私はまあポップカルチャーについて例えばアニメ漫画コスプレのようなことを
日本に関して書いてもいますそして日本は今空ジャパンキャンペーンという
の今実行中ですくるるじゃんということで日本の文化の空左往というの文化トップカン
ちゃんは通じて拡散をしています
でも私としては日本の政府に大勢そして日本に住んでいる皆様に対してお願いがあり
ます
あのクールジャパンだけではなくどもー
ペニもっと深い強みというものをたくさんをしてほしいと思うのですねそして調和と
安定性が大事にされている文化が取り難くすぐ確認
くっが起きませんブリクストン
よろしいと思っております
ありがとうございます